a seismic shift is happening within the
meat industry
social and economic trends like food
inflation and growing inequality
are converging with a rising
preference for plant-based diets
and that all together is impacting how
we consume meat
in many countries the pandemic has
shrunk people's wallets
problems with supply chains as well as
tight market for animal feed have
combined to
spark meat inflation while we are still
waiting for data to come through
interviews with many families from
around the world uh
confirmed that more and more people are
struggling
to obtain meat so have you reduced
your meat consumption or issues
even in the wealthier parts of the world
more people are getting priced out of
meat
in new york income is a stark driver of
meat spending
americans are now spending less on meat
at grocery stores
than they were at the start of the year
of course demand for meat
dipped during the past economic crisis
only to rebound but what is new this
time
it's happening at the same time as
consumers
are increasingly shifting to plant-based
diets
well we have seen an increase in the
retail demand
you know we grew 300 last year this
despite the
you know the pandemic i think
plant-based has has two
two good reasons to to keep going very
strong one is
environmental reasons and the second one
is now i would say personal
health and nutrition more conscious than
ever of meat's impact on the planet
human health and animal welfare a
growing number of middle class consumers
are reaching out for plant-based
alternatives
some estimates point to reduced spending
particularly for premium meats such as
beef
the most polluting animal product
in germany the number of vegetarians and
vegans doubled during the pandemic
while in france almost half of people
reduce meat intake in the last three
years
plant-based trends aren't limited to the
western world in china it's catching on
among the youth and can be seen at
trendy and upscale restaurants
all taken together this signals a
substantial shift for the meat industry
and offers some hope for a reduction in
global greenhouse gas emissions
of which meat is a major source but for
those struggling to make ends meet
not being able to afford meat often
means not having access to a key source
of nutrients in their diet
changes to the diet of brazilians
reflect the economic toll
from the pandemic and they also ripple
across emerging and developing countries
which until now have been viewed as the
major driver
of meat demand growth
[Music]
[Music]
foreign